oh my god I forgot ketchup caviar
I'm James Percy Oh director of culinary
research here at the Institute of
Culinary Education today we're gonna
make your Big Mac meal fancy so we're
gonna start things off here with a
little french fry mousse
we took our large french fries blended
them with a little bit of hot milk which
makes this beautiful creamy potato puree
and we're gonna load that into the
whipping canister here that's gonna
create a beautiful silky potato mousse
[Music]
all right so that's potato mousse now
ketchup caviar I love ketchup on my
burger ketchup can look a whole lot
better we're gonna start here with just
a bit of water and agar we're gonna take
that and whisk it into the water and
you're like a guren stead of gelatin is
that because it will stay gelled at warm
temperatures where gels is gonna
dissolve really quickly so the agar and
water mixture has come to a boil now we
just turn that down and add our ketchup
let that ketchup and anger cook together
for just a moment so agar and ketchup
mixture in the squeeze bottle this is
where things get fun we've got a bath of
cold oil so this is oil that's been in
the freezer and is now sitting over ice
so it's super super cold we take our hot
ketchup agar mixture and we're gonna
drop it into ice-cold oil so if we add
it drop by drop we're gonna get perfect
little pearls of ketchup really cool
little trick you can do this with any
kind of liquid fruit juices and and
really anything you want now we just
scoop these guys up and drop them into a
little water to rinse there it is
ketchup caviar
I think we're ready to play so here we
go we got our Big Mac when in grab a
plate of just some extra kind of typical
burger toppings pickles lettuce tomato
onion we got our mustard and ketchup
we're ready to go we're actually gonna
start here a little bit of ketchup and a
little bit of mustard all right you know
you need that on your burger right next
to each other and then gonna take a
paintbrush and just run that right
through nice little base there we've got
our french fry loose just going to kind
of drop a little bit of that down around
the plate that's gonna just kind of set
up the frame for our burger
now our Big Mac take this bad boy apart
I've got one patty with the cheese and
then another paddock so we're gonna put
take those two guys slice those and just
kind of frame them up and they're gonna
rest right here between that french fry
move so now we're starting to set up a
little bit of framing a little movement
on the plate bun is gonna give us some
nice little texture so I'm gonna take
that bun actually tear it into pieces
and just drop it right around here so
now we're starting to kind of fill out
this plate we're getting a good look
[ __ ] that right around there then our
little garnishes here so we've got our
pickles and just drop some nice pickles
right in there
the love pickles so we're going with
lots of these a little bit of onion tuck
those right in I love these little rings
right here now a bit of our tomato just
cut it up into some small pieces get
some different shapes happening so they
tuck right in and then finish it off
with some nice fresh lettuce here get a
nice little shape on the back just like
this drop three of those around there
I'm looking really good so our burger is
plated and then we finish it off with my
favorite piece that ketchup caviar it
would just grab a little bit of our
caviar there and now we're going to drop
it right in there
[Music]
and with ketchup caviar there it is the
Big Mac meal transforms
[Music]